Would it be possible to hit a few headlines
with one of my favorite OG Daily Show correspondents?
Go for it, let's see.
What do you got?
Well actually...
(audience cheering)
I'm gonna give you the first story.
Oh, all right.
Oh, here we go.
So a story from the BBC.
And you know how credit cards
now have that little contactless chip, right?
So you don't need to swipe.
You can just tap your card.
You don't need to swipe, right?
So now you can get that implanted in your hand.
Oh hot.
The chip is the size of a grain of rice
and is encased in biopolymer and you hold your hand
over a sensor and boop, your bill is paid.
Boop.
You can freak out your waitresses paying with your hand.
Now that is priceless.
Ooh, uh, I don't...
You know, I don't like this one bit.
You know, like that terrible nightmare
when you're at an auction and you wave at a friend.
Yes.
And then you just
bought a painting?
Yeah, yeah.
Imagine you just walk by beep, bop, boop.
Well, that's what I'm worried about.
I think this is gonna be a problem.
You could walk through Bed Bath and Beyond
and come out with a $6,000 bill
because you talk with your hands.
Yes.
You know, I just don't know.
I don't like it.
The only chip I want in my hand is a Pringle.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauding)
No, thank you.
I do have the watch though, where I can like pay
just like a double beep bop boop and that's easy.
So maybe they could do a ring or something,
but implanting it-
The difference is you can
take your watch off.
Yes, exactly.
And a ring, I'm into that.
That's cute, right?
Yes, a payment ring?
(gasps) Yeah.
I own it.
(chuckles) I'm just kidding.
Copyright.
All right, hey next, a British group
called UK Antarctic Heritage Trust.
They're looking for three people to run
the most remote post office in the world in Antarctica.
Yeah, Travel Leisure reports,
"The job runs November through March",
which is apparently the best season in Antarctica
and "Ideal candidates must enjoy adventure,
be willing to count penguins for an ongoing penguin study,
be okay with absolutely no internet or cell service."
And a small thing.
"There are no showers or running water."
All right?
So, is the no running water because it would just freeze?
Is that what's going on?
And like, also then like, then what?
Then what?
Where do we go from there?
I dunno.
How do we be hygienic?
Gross.
I'm not moving to Antarctica.
There's only like two people down there.
So it not like, you know...
Like the penguins are like, "Pew wee."
(all laughing)
Well, speaking of animals, we have news from Arizona
where a wild javelina got stuck in a hatchback
after it went looking for cheese puffs.
The owners left the hatchback open overnight
and the javelina sniffed out the cheesy snack.
Oh my gosh.
But his weight closed
the door behind him.
So he chewed off part of the dash
and part of the door.
And he knocked the car into neutral
and ended up across the street by morning.
No one was hurt, including the hungry, hungry javelina.
And the local Sheriff's office
has issued a reminder to residents quote,
"Don't feed the javelina."
I will say this javelina looks like me
in my kitchen at night.
(Ross laughing)
Like thrashing, cheesy snacks everywhere.
I relate to this javelina.
Oh my God, I love cheese-
I feel bad for this javelina.
Like the poor thing that was going after the cheese...
Why would you leave cheese puffs in your car
and the door open if you live in an area
that has these pig rodents running around?
(audience laughing)
I mean, don't you think like...
Well, I can tell you with certainty,
this would never happen to me
because I would never leave cheese puffs.
Girl, I'm eating all of those.
That's not happening to me.
(audience applauding)
Aasif Mandvi, can you come back?
Yeah, I'll come back whenever you want.
Really?
Yeah.
I wanna do this with you more often.
Yeah, let's do it.
Okay, great.
Well, watch episodes of, "Would I Lie To You?"
every Saturday on the CW and watch Aasif in the new show,
"Evil", seasons one and two,
now streaming on Paramount Plus,
and season three is out June 12th
because that show is huge.
People love...
Yeah, we have crazy fans on that show.
Crazy fans.
It's good.
It's a lot of fun.
I'm so happy for all your success.
Oh, thank you.
Evil, a game show,
Daily Show, come on Aasif.
And you can still watch "Music and Lyrics".
It's still out there somewhere.
And that's a great move too.
(upbeat music)